movemos rusia también tiene unos aliados
muy fuertes que están detrás de todo en
este contexto como a la sombra podríamos
decirlo unas naciones de medio oriente
también de igual manera china lo sabemos
que tiene ahí una relevancia específica
y esto tiene que ver con un con ese
cambio de que lo que también le interesa
putin ver qué es la desglobalización que
lo que estamos viendo y continuando con
lo que decía lorena en su intervención
muy importante también ver lo que no
solamente a putin le interesa que
ucraniano entre a la otan sino también
que se retire una cantidad de naciones
del báltico como república checa-
precisamente polonia que están bien en
estos días se ha dicho que
potencialmente podría haber un ejercicio
militar por parte de putin por
kaliningrado ahí en la frontera entonces
obviamente las señales fueron claras
alemania estuvo ahí francia y también se
ve como como han perdido relevancia
internacional en los últimos tiempos